[Applause]
okay Liz do you worry deep fake videos
will influence future elections and what
should we do about it tell them first
what a deep fake video is I think there
was one recently is probably the example
that most people are going to be
familiar with somebody obviously did
this video that sort of slowed things
down and made her look totally
shit-faced which is an interesting look
on the Speaker of the House of
Representative or to which it was
I think seemed a little more plausible
to some people disturbingly yeah this is
a very tricky question this is the
second interview I've done in a week
where I've been asked this and I don't
have great answers I hate to always be
the person who has to say everybody's
least favorite thing which is I have no
[ __ ] idea but to some degree I have
no [ __ ] idea on this I think if you
are Nancy Pelosi in you're somebody who
has that stature I think the way that
she handled it in rebutting it and
ensuring that people knew that it was
fake was pretty effective but you know
to pick on my least favorite
presidential candidate again for the
second time in a night if you're Bill
DeBlasio and basically I mean somebody
could do anything the only the only
thing about Bill DeBlasio is that
possibly the fake video would actually
be like more appealing what what what
are you [ __ ] murderers groundhogs and
eats pizza petty [ __ ] oh whatever
what happened a really good mayor of New
York City which has never been a
springboard to national office but let's
stop sitting on Bill DeBlasio because
he's a powerful kind of Democrat in the
left is Goodwin groundhog murdering
pizza eater with a knife and fork who
supports the [ __ ] Boston Red Sox in
New York City I don't that have to do
with [ __ ] anything
[Applause]
he dropped the groundhog at a groundhog
day thing and then it later died his
groundhogs never do unless he dropped
but he didn't do it on purpose did a
groundhog that's what dad says
and he's and he's done a lot of things
in New York that are moving New York and
directions the rest of the country real
school lunches universal pre-k and the
work he's done a lot of both TV stars
who are the president correct well
actually know what but actually actually
go further back than that that's the
point I like to make it here that think
about we think about other options here
right JFK I mean you look at what
happened with JFK's military service
that easily could have been spun into a
tale of wow he actually [ __ ] up pretty
badly but instead a movie was made
depicting him as a hero that made it a
lot easier for him to springboard
himself to the Democratic nomination and
then to the presidency I love John
McCain worked for John McCain don't want
to say John McCain got the nomination
because he was a celebrity but dude like
some of the things there was John back
to Teddy Roosevelt sure the rough right
he wrote a book about it which critics
said was alone in Cuba that's the way he
portrayed himself as the great hero okay
Debra what do you think about tech
companies like YouTube starting to ban
extremist views so I torn all this
because obviously I don't think hateful
content is a good thing don't it makes
me uncomfortable to think that people
are going on there and becoming
radicalized at the same time I don't
think censorship is a good solution
because I think it only adds to the
polarization it adds to the frustration
and it's not just YouTube that is guilty
of this I mean the social media
platforms across the board are doing it
part of the problem with that are the
algorithms and social media companies
that feed someone who finds their way to
an extremist video a steady diet of more
and more extreme videos the New York
Times had a great cover story on it a
week ago Sunday about the radicalization
of this white kid in the basement
because he started watching YouTube
videos and was just fed a steady diet of
like further and further right YouTube
videos and it's how the algorithm
YouTube
just like fed that yeah it's happening
to kids in a big way you know but but is
the answer censorship we wouldn't need
to censor the the source of those videos
if the algorithms were premiering so
effectively Tom does New York's plan to
cut greenhouse gas emissions by 2050 oh
that's bill de blasio it's that's gonna
do it by killing all the ground girl
Cosmo Cortes was so wrong with the cow
far to the [ __ ] ground yeah all right
anyway New York has apply read this to a
plan to cut greenhouse visions by 2050
2050 this [ __ ] country can't do
anything 2050 we got 10 years to figure
this out and get down to they said that
in 2003 10 years yeah that's what that's
what did NASA dude what's his name James
I'm talking about you know an
international body of scientists that
you know within 10 years we've got to
make these changes I really I've been
hearing that tenure thing for a long
time that tenure clock is big it's
seriously day after tomorrow did nobody
else watch that I mean dude should have
watched it people that have been paying
attention took out the Capitol Records
building in LA people that write well
you know what I know I know you're being
facetious but everything that happens in
movies first that happens I'm not I'm
not 100% be facetious one of my worries
about climate change is a Republican who
actually does believe in it is I think
it's wonderful that we're gonna have
lots of discussions about shifting
towards a carbon-free future I think we
might have already [ __ ] ourselves
quite some time ago so I don't even know
I feel like we may be in a space where
it's adapt or die time well right now
Republicans have fled Oregon to prevent
the Oregon State Legislature from acting
on climate change Republicans are the
worst actors and they have been walked
out adopt winding down though is
somebody who lives in Seattle can we
just can we have a little private
agreement here the people from Oregon or
just like naturally hey I learned in
Oregon
and the reality is they're shutting down
the legislative process because they
disagree with it you know what there's
no thousand and nine there was a
business man's letter written to Donald
Trump which said the science is
referable unless we take immediate
action on climate change the
consequences are going to be
catastrophic you know who signed that
bill Donald Trump Donald Trump jr.
Ivanka Trump and Eric Trump 2009 what
changed not the science climate changes
even more here but Donald Trump suddenly
realizing hey if I'm gonna make it in
Republican politics I have to switch to
be a denier it's all bogus on his part
Wow I'm starting not to like him Dan
what do you think will come of Roy
Moore's 2020 Senate run Roy Morris he's
running again he's likely to get the
nomination because really looking bass
is odious and hateful and he's been
gonna lose the election again to lose
and Jeff Sessions gonna run against him
very well no I don't think so actually
there's another guy and I'm blanking on
what his name is but Eric Erickson has
endorsed him over Roy Moore and there
are people like that who are trying to
push him that guy maybe could be a
contender but based on a guy whose name
you can't remember drop a rodent do you
know that about
so just to tie in the animal rights
connection now all the polling that I
have seen also does indicate Alabama
Republicans are down with doing this a
second time and let's just go ahead
state Supreme Court over and over and
over again they love this alleged child
rapist who is also a horse abuser I just
want to be clear about I'm gonna say a
big thank you to HBO and all the
brilliant people who always cover for
this narky host I appreciated all 500
shows I can't believe it I'm only 35
thank you
[Applause]
you